[APPLAUSE]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all
are so sweet to me.
I'm so glad I didn't
wear my shoes.
Y'all make me feel good.
Do you know this is what
I absolutely love to do?
So y'all make me feel like
they're going to have to turn
the lights out on us tonight
because I'm going to keep
on singing.
I love you, Ryan.
Ryan told me to keep singing
'til the exit sign goes off.
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "PININ"]
There's a lady from
Atlanta, Georgia
who says something like--
[MUSIC, AVERY SUNSHINE,
"MIDNIGHT TRAIN TO GEORGIA"]
Y'all too young for that, huh?
[MUSIC, AVERY SUNSHINE,
"MIDNIGHT TRAIN TO GEORGIA"]
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "PININ"]
Sometimes you've got
to close your eyes.
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "PININ"]
Anybody ever get
good and you just
go-- anybody ever pined
over anybody or anything?
What-- the word "pine"
means to long for something
that is not there.
I'm by myself.
I know somebody in here said
they needed some Excedrin
from Duane Reade and they was
going to go out real quick,
and they were really
going to do a drive by.
[LAUGHTER]
I know I'm not by
myself, so if I'm not,
I just need you to do
this a little bit with me.
All you've got to do
is say, "pinin.' "
AUDIENCE: Pinin.'
AVERY SUNSHINE: Pinin.'
AVERY SUNSHINE: They're
not singing over there.
They don't pine. [INAUDIBLE].
Say, "pinin.' "
AUDIENCE: Pinin.'
AVERY SUNSHINE: Pinin.'
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all going
to sing with me tonight.
Oh yeah.
Say, "pinin.' "
AUDIENCE: Pinin.'
AVERY SUNSHINE: Pinin.'
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "PININ"]
[APPLAUSE]